to be clear i don't want to make any
any physiological claims about how this
is going to affect the structure or
function of any particular soft tissue
not making any any prehab or rehab
claims or anything like that just
in general if this is a problem you're
you're dealing with
tends to feel nice uh and and training
when you feel nice is good
yeah it's uh
when you start i was googling something
as you were talking because this got me
thinking i was like you know back in the
day uh around 2012 2013 i started doing
hamstring curls before my squats
and i was like i think i might have got
that from john meadows you probably did
and so i was googling it and i did yeah
and i was looking at an article he wrote
about it and in the article he said in
two different spots and this is a short
article i don't know why it works he's i
don't know why it works and i do not
have scientific evidence this is not
science yeah this is [ __ ] i do that
feels good yeah and uh and i think
that's an important thing in like the
whole evidence-based fitness world is
like
it is okay like it there's nothing wrong
with saying like hey this is like
something that is not dangerous is not
deleterious
it seems to work nice and i don't have
scientific evidence for it
yeah do with that what you will no like
that's something that i've talked about
a lot before like i think um
like i mean the the key for example
earlier in this episode is is a great
example of that like i think a lot of
people get themselves in trouble
because
they are unwilling to have the
intellectual humility to say
like hey
this thing seems good like it
uh
it's a practical approach that seems to
work for me and you know if you're
having similar problems to the ones i'm
having maybe it's worth you
experimenting with it as well like
that's
that's a perfectly valid thing to say
um
it's very intellectually honest way to
approach things where there's not a ton
of conclusive evidence one way or the
other or just not any direct research at
all um
and i i think people are
are unwilling to do that because
they maybe think it makes them sound
dumb or like less serious or they think
that
people won't take their advice as
seriously unless they
make it seem like everything they say
has a ton of supporting evidence but no
i think it's important to
be able to be honest about
what level of evidence supports the
things you say
and if it is just purely anecdotal just
say
this shit's anecdotal seems nice um
but yeah like the the the carb night
stuff if kiefer just came out and said
like
yeah man like if you're
struggling with like food fixation
through the day and and controlling your
total calorie intake yeah mostly just
eat protein through the day try eating
some carbs at night seems to work pretty
well for me give it a shot i don't think
anyone would have been upset about it
but that was a very controversial
dietary approach uh
because he went out on a limb and said
like yes like this is going to be
magical for these reasons and it was
just like
completely [ __ ] like massively over
extrapolated like basic physiology stuff
that didn't actually support the claims
he was making and like i feel that i
feel that same way about um
about like paleo stuff like
as far as kind of like popular fad diets
go uh the
the general dietary approach that paleo
folks recommend is perfectly reasonable
it's like yeah you know mostly stick to
unprocessed foods when possible um
i mean there are so many different
schools of paleo but like that's
basically it um like that's perfectly
reasonable dietary advice but you know
then when they say and this is going to
work the best for performance for health
for everything because like this is what
we evolved to eat and then like more
uh anthropological and paleontolo
paleontological evidence comes out
showing like oh yeah the way you said
paleolithic people ate yeah you're full
of [ __ ] they didn't eat that like then
paleo folks have egg on their face
because it's like oh yeah you said this
thing is good for these reasons
turns out the reasons uh are wrong and
you're an idiot but like the general
advice they're giving is often like
decent advice yeah and if they just
stuck with the decent advice of like uh
you know if possible eat less processed
foods um well i guess that's not the
best example because there is like
direct evidence on eating less processed
foods but like you get my point yeah you
know just just be honest about the level
of evidence you have supporting
something and in my case for my coach's
corner segment
i don't have evidence other than
feels nice for me seemed like it felt
nice for john meadows uh
maybe it will feel nice for you yeah and
just to reiterate there there's just
like some little qualifiers this whole
approach of like yeah it works for me
i'm gonna go ahead and recommend it to
people like
it's important to accurately present the
amount of support uh or lack of support
for that idea it's important that the
idea does not have uh
reasonable potential to be harmful or
deleterious right so it's it's very
different to say like hey like you're
probably going to be pretty good in
terms of your dietary goals if you
generally pick stuff from this whole
genre of foods versus like
you know just straight up
orthorexia inducing propaganda right
like the second you deviate from the
paleo foods like you're you're gonna get
sick dude like that's really bad yeah
like so there there's a fine line
between you know it got to be uh
stuff that is
doesn't have potential to be truly
deleterious or harmful
but also like the thing that drives me
nuts about anecdotes that are shared in
this context is again when people
just are unable to say like hey
this is anecdotal like when people take
these anecdotes and then just reach for
the closest science available and say
actually this is evidence-based science
uh that i'm giving you it's like yeah
it's not though so
as long as people are kind of putting
out the right caveats and not
recommending things that are reckless
like this kind of anecdotal stuff
certainly has a place in filling in the
gaps with uh with the way we approach
training and nutrition